foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where we help people build
wealth do work they love and create
incredible relationships I'm John
deloney joined here by George Campbell
and we are taking your calls on work
money life whatever you got going on we
probably have an opinion on it give us a
shout at triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five it is a
packed audience out there today packed
and it's good to see everybody let's go
out to John in Greenville North Carolina
what is up John how we doing man
hey I'm doing well how are you all
excellent my brother what's up
uh okay so two questions um I'm looking
for some advice and a career change
and also transition from Whole Life to
term life and I kind of want to know
what to do with the money that they're
going to send back to me
um so I'm 41 I've been in education
about 17 years in administration at a
Middle School uh can we just stop right
there God bless you dude it's amazing
God bless you man
thank you I have I have a middle
schooler one who lives at my house
wow and I'm trying to administrate that
and God bless you dude incredible thank
you okay thank you there is no job on
Earth you can't do so there you go all
right I appreciate it go for it
uh yes sir so in listening to the show
I've been listening to the show off and
on but I really made a strong commitment
back in January of this year so I won
about 121
797 in debt of that it's consumer that
about 60 000 and then the mortgage on my
home is about 61 000. so wanting to
expedite you know getting out of debt
but also realizing that I'm pretty much
capped in my salary
um unless I go into being a senior
principal which the working conditions
is worse than what I have now um so I'm
thinking about a career change and
trying to navigate that so are you
wanting to change careers because of the
income or are you wanting to get out of
an Administration and do me a favor talk
directly into your phone for me
yes sir there you go a little bit of
both a little bit of both
I'm gonna get out because I I don't
think it's going where I needed to go do
you want to stay in Greenville
yes sir okay what's your current income
um 85 000 a year okay
all right now you said you have a whole
life policy what would you get from that
once you cancel it
yes sir I've canceled it through Xander
and so they quoted me at about five
thousand four hundred some dollars and
45 days from when I canceled it which I
think is March of this year is what I
can expect and I don't really know I
know there's going to be some taxes
involved so I'm a little worried about
that too
okay and do you have any other money
right now in savings
uh my emergency fund I'm on baby step
two okay so you've got a thousand bucks
in the bank
and the rest has been going towards the
debt
yes what is this Consumer Debt is it
student loans
get it lows yes
um and then about three credit cards
and you've been carrying the student
loans for the last 17 years
uh um yes including like the Masters
that I got so it's kind of been a little
bit here and there you've collected some
along the journey
yes okay are you married you have
somebody to pitch in and help or are you
single
single all right we're continually
married but you know working 12 hours a
day it's kind of hard I am you're
impressive well the good news is making
85 000 can you pay off 60 absolutely
you can be done with this in less than
two years
okay so that's not a I wouldn't change
careers because your financial situation
is on fire I would change careers
because you want to change careers
okay yes sir do you know what you want
to do or do you want to stay in in the
education world or you want something
completely different
I've been kind of looking at some things
in it and I've taken like a little boot
camp course and it was really intriguing
I didn't work on it
um just a little nervous about jumping
into that because it was the entry level
and I need to get certifications and
stuff
finally the time to study for that has
also been an issue but
yeah I'm going to tell you something I
hate to say this because I've actually
I've been in a education administrator
for most of my career so I
I think there's an opportunity and it's
going to be a very unpleasant one as
George was pointing out I think there's
an opportunity for 24 months of staying
in your current job even if you just
made one of those chains that you make
when you're a kid of out of construction
paper and you just tear a one off every
month I got 24 of these months and I'm
going to work these long 10 to 12 hour
administrative days and then on
Saturdays and Sundays when I'm not at
games and I'm not running around at
whatever we're doing right at band
ceremonies or whatever I'm gonna start
branching out into some of these this it
world and you can do part-time I.T work
you can do on the side it work and make
no mistake dude in 24 months you're
going to be so tired you're not gonna be
able to form sentences you're gonna be
exhausted but you will have you will
have a paid all this crap off you're not
going to have enough time to go out and
do anything and that's good and you're
going to
have been able to dip your toe in the
water and see if it is the job for you I
just this is just me I may be way out to
lunch I think that is a it's going to be
a tough toggle from being somebody that
all these kids love that's you know hey
Dr so-and-so or hey Mr so-and-so who
gets to help people and all of a sudden
you transition to just headphones on
zero one one one one zero zero one maybe
that maybe you're ready for that that
feels like
um an Educator's fantasy like I just
want no kids and no humans and
especially no parents and I just want a
screen and some headphones that will be
awesome for about two months and then
you'll be frustrated I like what George
has to say man if you clear this up and
begin to think like
do I like teaching do I like education
do I want to go teach the college level
do I just want to get out of the school
district because it's toxic or do I want
to go to private school I think clearing
some of this debt up is going to give
you a cleaner slate to think from does
that sound right
it does yes sir
so following the baby steps we're going
to ignore the Mortgage Debt right now
and just focus on that Consumer Debt and
making 85 000 even if you threw 30 of
the 85 towards the state you're done in
two years so my goal is to do it even
faster than that and do what it takes
cut the expenses work on the side if you
need to maybe even do some I.T side work
to start dipping your toes in that water
but here's what that's going to do for
you once you're debt free you could take
a pay cut you could take an entry level
I.T job making 50 or 60 and make that
work if you're debt free and so that
would be my fuel to get debt for even
faster is knowing that's on the other
side and John we also run into people
all the time who are debt free and
they're working at a pretty toxic job
and then they have this newfound power
this new found Freedom that when the
boss says hey I need you to to I know I
didn't tell you I'm so sorry it's Friday
afternoon at four o'clock I need you to
be here tomorrow morning at 8 A.M for
the to open up the doors for the band
concert and you just look at them and
you go I'm not doing that like I've
already got plans I'm not going to be
here and you owe nobody anything and
it's basically I call I call you I'm put
your cards on the table you're not gonna
fire me and they don't they find
somebody else they just been picking on
you and you've just been saying yes
because you're you think you're 120
Grand in the hole and you can't breathe
man you clear that stuff up and your job
suddenly the light comes on a little bit
and it becomes more of something that's
gonna make you happy not something
that's just killing you John I'm gonna
send you our friend Ken Coleman's get
clear assessment to help you with the
career side and every dollar plus to
help you on the financial side when it
comes to making a plan for these dollars
love it love it love it thanks for the
call John AAA 825-5225 this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
sir
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
thank you
welcome back this is the Ramsay show
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we're talking money mental health
marriage life whatever's going on in
your life give us a shout triple eight
eight two five five two two five I'm
John deloney joined here by George
the great camel wow I forgot that was my
middle name
for asked us to call you so there you go
self-proclaimed well John uh I'm on the
internet and I see this article and it
just I thought I like to grind your
gears and so I think this one might do
that I want to get your take on it
and here's the gist of the story it's my
hot take as the kids say right yes
please never use that term uh you got it
we're done with that okay so this woman
recently gives birth
and her husband demands that she pay the
entire hospital bill herself
now there's more to the story they've
been married seven years she just had
her their first baby three months ago
they split everything in their marriage
50 50 when it comes to finances and
generally keep their money separate
and everything seemed to be going pretty
well until they received a hospital bill
for this birth so here's the deal she
planned to give birth without any
medication but after 24 hours of Labor
decided to do the epidural and when the
bill came her husband expected her to
pay the entire eight grand Bill herself
and when she asked why he said you're
the one who couldn't hold out for a few
more hours and you jacked up the bill
and I shouldn't have to pay for all
these extra requests and then finally if
she wanted luxury she should expect to
pay for it oh my God if you tried that
on Sheila what would happen what hell
would break loose here's the thing I
wouldn't even be I wouldn't know you
wouldn't get the sentence Because by the
time those words left my mouth I would
already be at the gates
and I don't know which set of gate I
would be at if I said something like
this now if you're wondering all the
extra you know what jacked up this bill
well of course the epidural very
expensive uh lactation consultant
Nursery fee extra night stay postpartum
supplies any food she ate so all of that
made the bill go up and so he goes well
that was your decision so you should pay
for that that's not coming out of my
pile of the pot so she ended up paying
the entire bill on her own and she's now
wondering and questioning are her
feelings valid John okay so I had
somebody call my show a few years ago
and here's the question
um it she had a two-year-old and a seven
month old and she was with her boyfriend
and he let her know
um I want to let you know that um I'm
not considering you
for the role of my wife but two things
you're gonna have to a get my house back
in order because this place is a wreck
like you're just not taking care of the
house and B you're gonna have to get
your body back because let's be honest
you let that sucker go and when you get
that back and she and here's the deal
she was calling me to ask
how she could be more disciplined and I
was like oh honey like oh man
two friends that would not mind going
back to jail what's his address all
right so it's a it's a it's easy when
you're
when somebody is is
so is gaslighting you so bad is is so
out to lunch you think you're the start
to look in the mirror and be like oh it
must clearly it's me I'm the problem
it's not them yes they've been very
clear that it's it's not it's not them
it's me I'm the problem yes
wow so this is an abusive relationship
very clearly but it's an insane
relationship and but here's the thing I
do want to call out to there's I don't
have 10 million people listening right
now half of you and I know it's half of
you because that's how much negative
negative press we get
I'm never gonna I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna share a checking account I'm not
gonna share bills we split this thing 50
50. this is the end result of that and
if it's not if you're like no no I mean
I would help with the with the baby
where's your line dude when you set up a
my life in your life and we're married
into the same roof this is the root of
that crap that happens right this is
this is the end result down the road of
people who don't say hey we're married
we're in come hell or high water we're
both in on this deal this is that bull
crap like oh sorry bro you should just
held out bro
so he's driving a truck through you he's
like well you should have just should
have just hung out man I don't know how
this man is still alive truthfully what
an idiot so I don't know I mean
truthfully I don't know if the marriage
is going to survive if this is how it
continues if this is the attitude
towards it and we know that divorce and
money fights are one of the leading
causes uh money problems and money
fights leading cause of divorce another
leading cause of divorce made sense when
you look at being married to an idiot
that's another one or absolutely more a
poor choice was made at some point but
we teach people that you should combine
finances 100 when you get married
no earlier
but as soon as you're married combined
finances you're a team it's we it's not
well that's your bill so well I'll cover
electricity you cover the wad I I got
the food last month when we ate out
that's an insane way to live if you
wanted a roommate don't get married is
that simple yes
if you want to go back to being
roommates you can do that and by the way
for the first time in uh Ramsey show
history we're gonna add a few other
recommendations husbands don't look at
your wife and say an epidural is a
luxury you could have waited a few more
hours don't ever say that ever never say
that
um lactation consultant not a luxury not
a luxury here's a here's the thing
gentlemen in case you don't know this
babies
and uh have to eat they have to eat
um here's another one Nursery fee so
babies can stay in the room with you is
it insane that hospitals charge that yes
it is but
um I don't know throughout all of human
history until about 60 years ago babies
always slept in the same room with their
new parent like dude don't be insane
don't be Georgia man I told you it was
gonna grind your gears this is the
opposite of hemorrhoids this has got me
so puckered up I want to know this guy I
want to find this guy wow we went from
visual to visceral thank you John I I
can't I'm I'm just trying to imagine how
this would go in my house and I just
wouldn't here's what would happen you
and and probably Dave and maybe Rachel
there'd be a couple of y'all at this
desk and there'd be a box of tissues and
you'd just be saying like John's dead
John's dead and uh he won't be doing the
show had a good life he had a good life
but man he sure was stupid when it came
to one of his children being born wow
all right that's enough of that John
well thanks for I need some good news
thanks for making my day uh let's see if
Erica can help us out let's go to Erica
in Cleveland Ohio what's up Erica
yes Save Me
save me
hi my name is Erica I'm from Cleveland
how are you doing today John and George
we're making it we're making it hey
we're kind of up against the clock so
right into your question
okay
um that was an accident in January the
insurance company or the other person
found me at fault and they said
um sent it to the corrections for five
thousand dollars and I was trying to
figure out what can I do because I don't
even know where to begin
so you were in a wreck
um you were at fault and they had the
five thousand dollar judgment against
you and I'm assuming you don't have five
thousand dollars to pay
no
okay and they've all it happened in
January and they've already sent it to
collections yeah yeah yes they
said a letter
like
uh this week actually Four collections
already okay they sent me the letter for
saying I was at fault last week and sent
me the corrections without their full
collections this week it may not be
collections yet it may just be like a
they want payment like if they just now
yeah who yeah who wrote the letter
uh I don't know it just said some kind
of collection agency okay
um I would call them back
and
I would be very direct with I just got
this piece of paper that says I'm at
fault I've had no time to review it I
haven't had time for my attorney to
review it I just got this thing and then
all of a sudden you guys are calling me
for five thousand dollars which I don't
have right now I'm gonna have to make
arrangements I'm gonna have to call you
back
um and then you're gonna have to sit
down and come up with a plan for this
five thousand bucks
um if there's a judgment there's a
judgment do you have any other debt yeah
um that's that's it as student loans in
the house no okay and I don't really
know how much my student loans are
exactly well we got some homework to do
Erica make sure let's figure out exactly
how much we owe let's list it all out
and let's take care of this collections
before it accrues any penalties or
interest or fees but if you owe it let's
just make a plan to pay it I'm gonna
send you Financial Peace University it's
going to walk you through our proven
plan to get out of this mess and start
building for the future instead but uh
it's five grand and it feels like a lot
right now one day you're gonna look back
and go that sucked remember that yes but
you gotta gotta gotta pay it don't
ignore it because it's gonna double and
triple on you then you're gonna get the
only way yeah to pay it off that's right
this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
C of chm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
foreign
this is the Ramsey Show triple eight
eight two five five two two five is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go out to Charlie in Virginia
Beach what's up Charlie
hi so I bought my house this past
November and after finding Dave I
realized that it was a very poor
financial decision that's a big one
yes my boyfriend and I are considering
getting married and I'm just wondering
if I should save some money to be able
to sell my house as I'm in baby step two
how much debt do you have
um 395 is the mortgage and I have 81 in
student loans
okay when do you plan on getting married
um probably before next year 2024. has
he even proposed yet
we have talked oh Charlie they all talk
the old talk it could be 2029
no I promise it's not
oh sounds like she knows when we don't
there's an ultimatum in place John uh
yes he's also listening on the radio
right now well he's done on the ball
here just stop waiting around okay so
what makes you want to sell this house
that's a very big decision is just is
the mortgage way too much comparatively
to your take-home pay
it's astronomical wow it's give me a
number here what's your takeover 24.
um I take home I take home about 30
under 8K
so about 8K and the mortgage payment is
how much
two thousand five hundred twenty four
dollars okay
and I have a COA of 180 a month okay on
top of that so we'll include that in
numbers
so you are I mean that's is that on a 30
year
it is a 30-year okay it's like 31
percent
I think
so we're looking at over 30 probably
closer to a third of your take-home pay
which is a lot it's not on fire I
thought you're gonna tell me it's 50 60
of your take-home pay
and if you get married his his salary
comes on top of that too right
yes so
the question is what is your household
income versus your debt
um
right now we're just looking at Charlie
solo
oh it's it's just the AKA months you're
so that's your take-home pay
yes and how much debt do you have total
81k and is that all student loans oh no
with a with a mortgage it's 476k
together we're just looking at the
Consumer Debt so you have 81 000 student
loans
yes okay
now with your take-home pay you could
pay this off on your own you're making
about a 100K take home almost
and so could you take you know 40 Grand
a year and throw it at the stat and be
done in two years especially if you're
married inside of that you're going to
have combined incomes you're gonna have
a bigger shovel to throw at this debt
is he bringing debt with him
no he's a lot smarter than me oh does he
have a house
he does okay so what what's the plan if
you guys get married would you sell this
one anyways
I would want to sell my house because he
has a better house oh okay I have a Town
tone he has a real home and how long wow
shots fired Charlie shots fired I love a
town home
okay so either way you're gonna sell
this house down the line
yes my gut tells me we can sell it when
the time comes to sell it because right
now you're gonna sell it and then rent
somewhere in Virginia Beach right
um yes yes that would be the plan and if
you sold it what would you net profit
after all the fees
I wouldn't profit anything I would have
to save to
sell it because it's only appraised at
3.99 so you'd be underwater on this
thing
yeah yeah so it's it's not really doing
you any favors other than getting rid of
your mortgage payment which is just
going to be replaced with rent
and so I don't I don't think the house
is the problem right now uh I think it's
getting on a budget and seeing if we can
even increase the income and maybe we
can get rid of this debt before marriage
that'd be a cool goal
that's what I want to do to be able to
cash flow the wedding start our marriage
off completely debt free you move into
his place we have a big shovel now we
can start attacking the house I like
that plan
you listening David okay he's listening
but hey but here I want to tell you this
Charlie and this is not
um John and George Debbie downers okay
the Temptation here is to say okay we
have a plan that's going to be a
two-year plan and inside that two-year
plan we're gonna move into his house
we're gonna sell my house we're gonna
get married and we're gonna live happily
ever after
the reason we tell folks don't play
house
there's the moral sideways move that
over there's a math problem here okay
and so
the number of of relationships right
where you are that don't end up getting
married or something comes up or becomes
like let's just wait I want to wait
another year and then another year it's
it's lots and lots and lots and lots of
them
so as hard as this is I want you to do
two things at the same time I want you
to make plans for the future right
you'll continue down you'll talk about
marriage make him propose to you in the
right way and do all that fun stuff and
I want you operating as though you are
on your own
okay absolutely and do both at the same
time but that means
man it may come time to to
you may need to get rid of this house or
you want to get rid of this house but
don't blame Dave and don't blame this
marriage for it let's do it when the
time is right in the right order right
when you're getting married we're gonna
we're gonna move in together cool now we
gotta get rid of these places there's
gonna be a lot less pressure that way
then suddenly you sell this place and I
guess that's got to move in or I got to
get an apartment and it gets all wonky
and everybody gets sideways does that
make sense
yes yes doing the right order but good
for you and David get on the ball this
weekend what are you waiting for
poor David no no poor David he's
listening right now go he can't even
defend himself he's probably I plan on
it John all right sorry if I ruined it
David George I did that one time I had a
former student of mine I was walking out
of a restaurant and a former student of
mine was sitting at a just at a booth
um and I slid into the booth and there
was a woman sitting across from him and
I looked at at her and him and I was
like what are you doing and he
introduced me to her and I was like are
you with him and she's like yeah I
looked at him and said you're ridiculous
you're gonna let her get away you're
just messing her I haven't seen him
forever you're just messing around
screwing around and she's gonna leave
because you won't don't have the courage
to just get married I was just I had
never met her I just basically just
trolling just absolutely trolling and he
looks at me and he looks at her and he
reaches under his leg throws the ring
down on the dinner table and goes well
you ruined that one deloni and oh no
that's how that's their proposal story
and I was like I think it's probably
time for me to go sorry yeah never again
never don't ever let John slide into a
booth if you're trying to propose that
is correct a very specific scenario that
applies to almost no one but it does
provide it does it does apply to David
and Charlie David needs to get on the
ball here
um let's see here let's run out real
quick to Peter in buildings Peter we're
right up against the clock my brother so
let's get right to your question
can you hear me yes sir get right right
to the question
okay so my wife and I are both 26 years
old and we got married last year and
since then we've paid off uh forty two
thousand dollars worth of cars awesome
and have money to pay off seventy five
thousand dollars with a student loans
we haven't paid it it's just a high
yield savings account because
um we want to see what happens with this
decision but we're ready whenever it
happens and so now we have no debt but
our mortgage and so we're maxing out our
401ks she's already maxed hers out to 15
and I just recently became self-employed
and I've heard you guys talk about
there's been some changes with Ross um
IRAs recently for people that are
self-employed and that's the route I'm
looking at going I know the regular Ross
only have a sixty five hundred dollar
limit annually like as far as
contribution limits and I'm wondering is
is that the best option to go with or
are you solo no employees
no employees yep okay my guess and this
is a hunch I want you to look into is
that the solo 401K would be your best
bet and you can only do that if you have
no employees traditional one uh you can
do a Roth solo 401K as well but that
will have giant contribution limits you
can there's a total of 66 Grand cap for
2023 because you can contribute as the
employee and the employer
oh okay so yeah I was thinking I just
couldn't see it on on E-Trade so I'll
I'll go back and look for that do your
homework on the Roth solo 401K you can
get in touch with one of our smartvester
Pros to walk you through this to help
you set this up but it's an incredible
tool for those that are self-employed
you don't have to retire broke if you're
an entrepreneur that's for sure way to
go Peter you and your new spouse are
crushing it that's incredible hey this
is the Ramsay show triple eight eight
two five five two two five give us a
shot we'll be right back
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
every time I talk about this upcoming
event I get more excited because it's
going to be incredible money in marriage
is back and this time instead of just
one night it's going to be an entire
weekend October 19th through 21st this
is months away so you got time to save
up for it join Rachel Cruz and me for
the money and marriage getaway and spend
an entire weekend unplugged from your
day-to-day life and simply focusing on
your marriage one thing I've seen across
the country where I'm traveling or doing
my show is over the last three or four
or five years couples have become
roommates couples have become great
co-managers of their house and they have
lost intimacy they have just gotten
sideways with one another and it's so
hard to find a bridge back even when
that bridge feels like it's only two
inches away and that's what this weekend
is for we're going to cover things like
money and budgeting with your spouse
we're going to talk about connection sex
and intimacy we'll get you planning for
your future together and this isn't what
you think of when you think of a
marriage conference not just going to be
you sitting there with a notebook being
a nerd you're going to learn a ton but
we're also going to give you and your
spouse time together throughout the
weekend to reflect and discuss what
you're on what you're learning and
actually come up with a real game plan
to take home with you Rachel Cruz and I
will be right there to coach you along
the way and answer your questions and we
have some incredible surprises that
we'll also be a part of this weekend we
can't wait for you to be there if you're
listening to this and it sounds like
something you and your spouse need I
want you to talk to your spouse about
this because listen tickets start at
6.99 which is a deal it's Madness for a
weekend uh marriage Retreat getaway and
this is going to be an incredible
experience go to
ramsesolutions.com
events to save your spot that's
ramseysolutions.com
events to save your spot can't wait for
that John my wife needs this she needs
to be at this event listen okay that's a
great point if you just heard that
announcement that that announcement and
you think my spouse really really
do not say it like that say Hey I would
like us to go to Nashville on a trip
together to a really fun cool marriage
conference so that we can get even
better
not that's the spirit you know what you
need honey you need you need marriage
couns you'll learn how to be a better
person and this is going to be fun most
marriages were free like it can be heavy
and you guys will get real but it's also
very fun it's you and Rachel it'll be
heavy but it'll be fun too it'll be fun
too and um it will not be weird that you
and Whitney are in the audience we'll be
there will you uh can I get a discount
absolutely not okay
let's go out to Grand Rapids Michigan
and talk to John hey John what's up man
hey guys how are you today good good
good what's happening
good hey John to start off wanted to say
thanks your show played part in saving
my marriage so appreciate that oh man
that very cool that means the world to
me dude thank you so much
you're welcome hey but Lauren Cohen
today
um
I am uninsurable as far as life
insurance goes
um and so I'm wondering what you guys
suggest as far as protecting my family
without being able to have life
insurance the traditional life insurance
I guess do you have a medical issue
yeah I have uh PTSD from the military
and that pretty much nixes any insurance
company willing to help me
and there's not there's excuse my
ignorance here there's I know about that
with civilians but there's not a program
that the military has to take care of
it's the people who've been taking care
of all of us
not as far as life insurance goes
um there's there is a company that
specializes in getting that it's not a
thing through the military but it's a
company that supposedly specializes in
getting life insurance for people like
me but they also denied me wow I I I
want this to be a like a moment of Shame
for our country
it's it's embarrassing and on behalf of
all of us I'm sorry I'm truly sorry
I appreciate that I I know they didn't
buy you a cup of coffee but it's it's a
as a taxpayer just a regular
knuckleheaded citizen I'm embarrassed
and I'm sorry
I'm sorry man all right I appreciate
that all right do you have any insurance
through your workplace even a small
policy
you could get no okay
um because I I I'm just on disability
through the VA I don't I don't have a
workplace okay
but there are my wife had my wife has a
real small one on me at hers I think
it's only like 30 000 but that's not
gonna help her save the house and
everything else if we if I die yeah the
one route I can that I could point you
to is a guaranteed issue policy which
wouldn't be a lot probably only up to 50
Grand
yeah but it might be an option your best
option really is to kind of become what
we call self-insured to where you have
no debt you get the mortgage paid off
you get a nest egg saved up and if
something happened your your family is
going to be okay
so John go ahead go ahead
um so that's what we're working at
obviously you can't get there overnight
um we are we're we're debt-free other
than our house but if I got in a car
wreck and died today she wouldn't be
able to keep the house she wouldn't be
able to afford it on just her income you
can also look into mortgage life
insurance which is going to be something
similar to where it would cover only
your mortgage balance
okay and so those are the mortgage
company or those separate
uh insurance companies that do that uh
it would be through a separate insurance
company and you can get in touch with
our friends at Xander to walk you
through your options for something like
that uh have you got in touch with them
yet
I did they denied me I didn't I didn't
ask about the mortgage when I was just
applying for life insurance and they
denied me as well yeah look into
guaranteed issue and mortgage life and
those might be your Best Bets outside of
just becoming self-insured but man I'm
so sorry you're dealing with this we got
to do better so let me say this Sean um
and you're a beacon of light out there
for folks
um this is one of those situations where
we want it to be different and it should
be different and it's not
right and you as somebody who's been I
mean you know this better than any of us
it shouldn't be this way we don't want
it to be this way and it is and so I
think setting down and say and spending
a time being frustrated like I am right
now is not gonna get you like I said
it's not gonna get you a cup of coffee
it's just going to further spin your
tires in the mud and so I would love to
to for you and your wife to go through
the mortgage life insurance to go
through this guaranteed issue and then
sit down and say okay here's our reality
we're going to choose reality now and
reality is nobody's coming to save us
and so let's get some mortgage insurance
that we're probably going to pay a
little bit we're probably gonna overpay
for it a little bit but it's going to
let us it's a sleep tax we're both gonna
be able to sleep and then we're just
gonna have to do things a little bit
differently
um we may have to be a Corolla family
for several years because
um we're gonna put a nest egg aside
because this is going to come we're all
going to end up dead we all know this
um and there's not a policy for you and
so I think you see what I'm saying
there's there's some empowerment with
owning reality once you get on the other
side of grief you know what I mean
yeah I got you okay I mean that makes
sense and yeah I'm a 04 Tacoma driver so
I got you hey man I'm an o600 guys so
there we go we can high five
um hey on uh I'm grateful for you thank
you for your service and thank you for
for loving us in ways that we're clearly
not reciprocating and there's something
powerful about owning reality here's
where we are and and George I think we
all do this in little ways and big ways
and when people call me and ask me about
how to fix my marriage what's going on
with my mental health it's often there
we want so badly something to be
different than what it just is I want my
husband to be more engaged I want my
wife to not talk down to me so much I
want my kids to fill in the blank and we
it's okay to grieve that but man you've
got to get to it's not so what are we
gonna do now right and making a list
writing down the things that we can
control the things that we can do which
is we can get out of debt we can live on
a budget we can get rid of that mortgage
once and for all once you do that you
can sleep better at night knowing you've
done everything you can do you put it on
the Dance Floor going I did everything I
can to protect my family but especially
for veterans John I know you have a huge
heart for vets out there but we got to
do better it just doesn't I can't I
can't wrap my head around it I just
can't uh I can't of all of the excess
spending and all of the nonsense that we
throw money around in this country
can't for the life of me and I hey
George I pride myself on being able to
see the other side of an argument I
think I think that's the that's the mark
of a wise person who can see the your
opponents somebody you disagree with I
know I get why they're there I get it
this is one that that the sacrifices
that that service men and women make and
that their families make because they go
A Year Without mom they go two years
without Mom or Dad and so they're
grinding it up too and the fact that we
don't have a plan to say Hey you put it
all out there for our country and for
men and women that you will never meet
we got you we've got you and we don't
have that we don't have that you get a
pamphlet and a high five and uh go get
them and I just I just is enraging if if
let me say this to the veterans out
there if I'm wrong please put into the
chat here where this where John can go
get some some help if there's services
that I don't know about please let us
know hey that's hour one in the books
here on the Ramsey Show we'll see you
again real soon we'll be right back
[Music]
thank you
hey it's John deloney co-host of the
Ramsey show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the Ramsey show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show live from Franklin Tennessee
where we help people build wealth do
work they love and create incredible
relationships I'm John deloney joined
here by one of the greatest humans who's
ever lived George Campbell and we are
taking your calls on life money
relationships marriage whatever you got
going on we probably have an opinion
give us a buzz at triple eight eight two
five five two two five the call is
completely free triple eight eight two
five five two two five we're not
supposed to talk about him but let's go
out to Bruno in Lincoln what's up there
Bruno how sick are you of that hey
what's up what's up guys how are you
good hey are you sick of the don't talk
about Bruno jokes because I'm just gonna
keep making them oh yeah yeah I hear
that a lot hey my name rhymes with a
with a bad lunch meat so same team all
right so what's up dude
um my question is uh is it better to
save only for a 20 down payment uh to go
ahead and purchase that house or may
wait for the next five years and then
buy the house cash
okay
walk us through this situation so you're
debt free with an emergency fund and now
you're looking to become a homeowner and
you're saying hey in five years I could
pay cash for a three four hundred
thousand dollar home
is that the idea yeah I'm looking at you
50 300 yeah that's the range okay and it
would take you five years to do this
based on your current income
yes all right yes you're correct here's
the way I look at this and John it may
have a different opinion I get worried
about waiting five years because we saw
what the housing market did the last
five years and so the house that you're
looking at that's 250 today could be 400
five years from now and all of a sudden
you're so excited you save 250 and now
you're still 150 shy
you see what I'm saying so it's a moving
goal post and so what I like to do is
just using the Ramsey parameter saying
hey if I did a 15-year fixed rate where
the payment was no more than a quarter
of my take-home pay what would it take
to get there and that number may be 25
down it may be 40 percent down but I I
don't know that I would personally wait
five years to become a homeowner if
you're financially ready
I see yeah okay it's an awesome goal to
have because you're also you're also
paying rent too on top of it yeah yeah I
would say we're not being like a huge a
month for rent is only 1300 bucks uh
we're fine where we are and uh it's it's
kind of a tough decision because
whenever I'm thinking on interest rate
how much am I going to be paying
interest uh even if I if I pay principal
early
but here's the thing burnout number one
you can always refinance later let's say
the rates magically drop back to three
percent we're all high fiving you can
always refinance later and number two
your goal should be to pay off that
house as soon as possible which is going
to save you probably six figures in
interest
so if you pay that house off let's say
you bought it in the next year and you
took the next four years to pay it off
well now you only paid five years of
Interest instead of what people normally
pay which is 30 years of interest at a
higher rate okay yeah so approach the
numbers and I still think it's an
awesome goal to pay cash but generally
we'd say hey if you can't save up and
pay cash for it within a few years it's
just a long time to wait while the
housing market keeps appreciating and
shifting
I see okay and it let's say if I if I go
ahead even though I can paint early is
it better to come up with a 30 years
mortgage or a 15 years old 15 only
and then you'd be about the business of
paying that thing off like a five year
seven year loan
that's great and you'll be better off
you'll be building Equity you're
basically locking in that housing price
and then building equity and paying that
thing off very quickly Bruno are you
married
yes I'm married is she sweating you down
for a house yep
um I could say it again is she sweating
you down for a house
uh no I had that's that's what happened
my wife just started working and now
we've finally we can breathe financially
and then we can start building up these
uh the saving accounts so we can start
looking at a house love it yeah I first
seen one year and a half we'll be able
to save enough for a 30 or a 40 percent
that's incredible my question yeah
that's awesome
yeah I've been waiting my entire life
through that and finally we got to the
point that
um we're we're very thankful for what
happened to our life so yeah dude I'm so
proud of you man you guys are in a great
spot and it's let me just say it's a
fantastic goal to pay cash for a house
that's the way we would always recommend
it if we could but we live in a fallen
world and so the only the only debt we
won't yell at you for is a 15-year fixed
rate loan let me make that clearly I
thought Dave said that's bad it is we
don't like it but we understand that in
today's world if we said you can only
pay cash for a house we would have zero
listeners left on the show these people
are insane that's right let's go to
Jason in Pennsylvania what's up Jason
uh good afternoon guys how are you great
how are you man not too bad so quick
question I'm going through some of the
steps that you guys put out there and
right now I'm sitting around forty five
thousand dollars in debt that will be
paid off in a maximum of four years with
if I continue doing the payments but I
also have 65 000 in classes
the capital gain would be fifteen
thousand
um where the capital gain tax I would
pay on it roughly 2500. okay that makes
sense to sell off that stock to cart to
eliminate that bet or is it it makes
perfect sense I would do it yesterday
all right and I say I've done this Jason
when I was in debt I had some old I had
a few stocks from Apple not nearly what
you have but it helped me pay off debt
and I've never looked back and you can
look at the numbers and go well what the
stock would have been but man single
stocks number one are super volatile and
that money is way better spent freeing
you up instead of doing this for the
next four years and you're still
definitely putting money on interest yep
yeah yes I yeah I'm 100 George any
stocks I'd sell them and get about it
set aside the money for those taxes but
man 2500 bucks in taxes to be debt free
today and still have almost 20 grand
left over done that's your emergency
fund too I mean you just get baby steps
one two and three just LeapFrog that's
right hey um before we head into
commercial break
it means a lot to people who have no
idea who we are when they are scrolling
around on YouTube and you have hit the
Subscribe button you've left a five-star
review it pops up in their feed it sends
this thing up into the magical wizard
algorithms and it gets the show in front
of more people who are sitting at home
with their face in their hands and
little kids running around they don't
know how they're going to pay their
bills
not asking for money not asking for
y'all to buy any of us like what we're
asking you to do is hit the Subscribe
button it doesn't make us it doesn't
give us any more money it doesn't make
us all feel better it puts this show in
front of other people it's a zero cost
way for you to help out your neighbors
and to begin to take into our own hands
this financial mess that our country is
in there is not going to be a savior on
a white horse on this one we're gonna
have to decide as neighbors how to do
this and if you've always wondered why
don't more people just do the Dave
Ramsey play a lot of people don't know
about it and so if you hit the Subscribe
button if you hit uh go to Spotify go to
Apple hit the Subscribe button if you
leave your five star reviews it just
kicks it up and puts the show in front
of more people and and um some more
people that can get get help and George
I've never in my life
would have imagined that I was asking
people to hit the Subscribe button yeah
generally you're doing it for validation
this is at a very pure motive and
intentions that he really just wants
impact exactly that's growth John I'm
proud of you I I it's it's such an easy
way to help out your neighbor these days
it really is hit subscribe hey this is
the Ramsay show triple eight eight two
five five two two five we'll be right
back
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
joined here by George Kimmel we're
taking your calls on your mental health
your marriage your money whatever's
going on in your life give us a shout
triple eight eight two five five two two
five and George I am usually not correct
but this time I was whoa this time I was
does your wife know about this she's
going to be ecstatic I'm going to keep
it to myself I need to put this one in
my back pocket just in case I need it at
a later date because you usually save
that as the great Social Distortion said
I am wrong okay so New York Times comes
out in uh a couple couple days ago the
New York Times the Dirty Little Secret
of credit card reward programs now for
years I've been saying
very they work they absolutely do work
and people always call us and like oh
you're telling me that you don't take
free flights and they for sure do if
you're just swiping the card I got a
buddy who puts a hundred percent of his
life on these cards everything on the
card so that and he pays off every month
and he just does it for the for the
free free miles or free whatever sure
that's a real thing that happens now
most people don't pay it off every month
and they're like no I was just going too
bro and they don't but fair enough there
are people who do
and my buddies were always surprised
that I didn't participate and I wasn't
me trying to take a moral High ground or
anything like that
but I didn't want to participate in this
program because I knew that these credit
card companies are not my friend they
don't like me they're not hooking me up
because I'm hooking them up it's not
like yeah bro let's do this we're in
this together I'll buy some stuff you
give me free flights that's not how it
works
somebody is paying for my flights and as
I dug into it a few years ago it
appeared to me
that the single mom with three kids who
can't float the price of eggs and the
increase in gas prices and the natural
gas prices she was paying for my flights
because she was having to put the stuff
on a credit card conceivably to survive
and so my free flights from being paid
for by people who had way less and were
struggling to to make it and turns out
was right turned into studies and data
that's incredible this is why okay tell
us about this okay so the you know it
goes on to talk about hey your these
swipes you're using to get first class
airfare and trips and all your Awards
it's it's not from nothing the credit
card perks for educated usually Urban
Pros are subsidized by people who have
less so poor consumers are ultimately
footing the bill and in 2022 a Federal
Reserve data show that the cost of
rewards as a share of total transaction
volume on these credit cards increased
25 percent from 2015 through 2021 and so
what's interesting John is the data was
so clear in this study it showed that 15
billion dollars in reward value move
from the poor to the rich from the
unsophisticated folks who couldn't pay
their bills on time to the affluent
wealthy and no normal people go well
yeah that's how the system is set up
John
so I'm just going to take advantage of
that why would I not but here's what's
Wild a lot of the people that come at us
going John's I can't believe John's
trying to use this moral angle to say
it's not coming from people who have
less than it's coming from swipe fees
from the businesses and interchange fees
and my annual fees but I looked at
Capital ones they put their shareholder
reports out every year and in Q4 of 2022
it turns out that two-thirds of their
credit card Revenue came from interest
and fees not from The Interchange not
from the other fees interest so
two-thirds is blood diamond money yeah
and let's also
it's also easier to to get on on a high
horse and say Well they're just making
dumb purchases and they don't know
if you've ever spent some time with
people on the margins so many don't know
right they haven't been told they're
just trying to claw their way out of the
world that they found themselves in and
they don't know that it's not normal to
roll fees over like this as they don't
know that a 30 APR isn't just the price
of doing life these days and so I
I don't know how people can look in the
mirror and say you know what I'm
comfortable with a single mom trying to
just trying to scratch through life with
her buying my flights because they're
free now like I just can't wrap my head
around to George and the other problem
is we're all paying for this through the
increased cost of goods the United
States has some of the highest credit
card processing costs in the world
typically two to two and a quarter
percent on every purchase and so the
merchants the businesses the small
businesses they have to pass these costs
on to the consumers by charging more for
the products regardless of how you pay
and you see you see some of the local
Merchants that will say here's the price
for if you play with the card oh here's
the cash price it's less and George I it
has I'm sure it's happened to you more
because you're out in the world more
than I am that's true but um I had my
first exchange the other day where I was
at a place I was traveling at a speaking
event I was out on the road and they
said we don't take cash here and it was
like I'm not gonna do business with you
just just on principle I'm staying in
business with you wow well the the date
is clear here John lower income
consumers are forced to pay higher
prices on the goods they buy but they
rarely receive any benefit from rewards
programs according to the Federal
Reserve and so it's been tracking all of
this and so to put another way they say
credit card awards are essentially a tax
on less affluent consumers who are much
more likely to pay for the goods with
cash debit cards or standard credit
products that accrue no such rewards so
you know you have a lot of people have a
lot of opinions about this but across
the aisle politically I mean NPR and Vox
and New York Times they're covering the
same thing going hey this isn't innocent
yeah someone is paying for this and it's
either the small business owner or the
single mom but you can't act like this
is just an innocent I'm just gonna rape
the rewards your free vacation came from
somewhere and we have to at least
acknowledge that that's right and if you
and and God bless you if you can sleep
at night knowing that um I pay my bills
I do my thing so I if that's that's I
mean if that's if you your conscience
can carry that weight more power and
even if you don't have a conscience
every single piece of data shows that
you spend more when you use a credit
card right every piece of data so
regardless if you're saying hey I'm
going to use every I'm going to use my
card for everything to get these rewards
the chances are you overspent to where
the rewards were negligible right you
you maybe got a thousand bucks in
rewards you spent more than a thousand
dollars than you were if you were gonna
use a debit card on a budget or using
cash so here's here like to me the
Cornerstone rule is opt out of the
system just opt out man this is like
Matrix style stuff but just opt out of
this I haven't had a credit card in 10
years and I can unequivocally say my
life has been better for it no question
not once have I wondered well they've
got five percent cash back on
restaurants this month so I gotta I'm
gonna switch the card I was hanging out
with some guys the other night they're
all personal finance you know influencer
type guys and they're all showing me the
different cards and this one's made of
three inches of metal and I get this
much rewards and I'm like guys you make
millions of dollars how much money do
you get back in rewards they were like I
probably got two grand worth of value
I went so you're playing this game for
two grand worth of value and you make
millions yeah why yeah exactly
it's a crazy I mean when you put it that
way you go is it like real life Dungeons
and Dragons you're getting paid 200 a
month to overspend and play this game
and support this system yeah it's just
not worth it for me I'm out I'm out I
opt out of the system opt out of the
system all right let's go to Silas in
Nashville down the street what's up
Silas how we doing brother
I'm doing good how are you guys doing
excellent what's up man how can we help
okay so um I'm uh 18 years old and I
just got a job making about 75 000 a
year wow congratulations what are you
doing man thank you I'm working on wind
turbines excellent no college degree
needed
very cool all right hey we're up against
the clock it writes your question
brother
so um I'm really trying to look in a way
to save for my kids so that I can take
off work I don't have any kids yet I
don't even have a girlfriend but I plan
on having kids in the future and I want
the first five years or so uh me being
able to spend a majority of time because
studies show that that's really
important uh spending time with your
kids at that age so I want to create a
short-term savings account for five to
ten years in the future but I can't find
really good rates on it like it's
usually like three percent for a bank
and so I was just curious what you guys
thought of like short-term uh savings
where should I put that money
I don't know that savings is the best
route to do this what you're essentially
saying is I want to be a stay-at-home
dad for five to ten years and I don't
want my spouse to work either yeah is
that the idea for five years yeah for
five years yeah I mean you might be
better off looking at some kind of
passive income it's not passive in the
sense that it won't take work but it may
be tough to save up you know four
hundred thousand dollars to live off of
for 10 years in the next five years
right so you can save aggressively a
high-yield savings account is good five
years or longer you can invest it into
the market but also live your life man
yeah and having having you might have
read some research but having one of the
parents working full-time is does not
negatively correlate
um childhood development so I don't know
what studies you're reading but
that's not accurate this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
Shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed Perfect Fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
thank you
what is up what is up this is the Ramsay
show triple eight eight two five five
two two five I'm John deloney joined
here by George Campbell and we are
saving the world Listen a lot of you
have questions about taxes we get it
taxes are confusing I think they're
intentionally confusing that's another
podcast to help you get a better handle
on them let's unpack a question from one
of our listeners I'm looking into Ramsay
smart tax and want to know if it offers
forms and online filing for state tax
returns is it as simple to use as Turbo
Tax great question yes you can add a
state return if you need one or you can
just move to Texas or Tennessee all the
information on your federal return is
automatically transferred to your state
forms it could not be much simpler than
that Ramsay tax is easy to use and gives
you access to all major federal forms
and deductions without any up charges
George uh this year I I got a tax person
for the first time ever but the last few
years I've just used Ramsey tax at my
kitchen table and it is so easy and just
knock out out right there and actually
like doing it at home
um because I like my kids watching I
think they get to ask questions and see
it like what's this for me what's this
for me they get to punch in some numbers
too for fun I don't let them touch the
numbers but I do let them know this is
how confusing the government makes it
just to exist when you switch from
another software Ramsay tax can save you
up to 70 percent plus we won't offer you
loans or credit cards most tax programs
are designed just to get you in the door
free tax free tax so that they can sell
you a bunch of crap we're not going to
do that we're not going to put you into
debt that's not how we do things here at
Ramsey if you're ready to file head to
ramseysolutions.com smarttax it's just
24.95 right now to file a federal return
39.95 for a state return that's
ramseysolutions.com
smart tax all right let's go out to
McKinsey in Orlando Florida what's up
McKenzie
Hi how are you great how are you
I'm really glad to be talking to you
guys we're here to save the day what's
up
uh so I'm 25 years old I have an
overwhelming amount of undergraduate
debt and I'm at a point in my life where
I'm hoping to be buying a house or
something but I know that the advice is
to lower the debt before buying a house
debt
um is
235 000
ouch wow that is a box of farts on a
pony McKenzie how how like what did you
study
I studied electrical engineering okay
did you do a special electrical
engineering like the secret underground
kind
no this is standard one unfortunately
um you just did it at 60 Grand a year
so
I just took a little longer I'm a first
generation college student and I kind of
you know there's a bunch of reasons that
I didn't really feel like I had like the
toolbox starting out and took me a while
to kind of get into the groove of things
sure so what are you doing now
I'm an engineer good that's a good start
what are you making
I make about seventy thousand okay and
what other debt do you have outside of
the 235
um I have no other I mean I have like
about a thousand dollars on a credit
card but okay well A1 let's pay that off
and cut up the card
that'll cut that crutch out of our life
and help us get rid of this debt so are
you calling to figure out how best to
pay off the debt
yeah I guess I'm looking at two options
uh kind of waiting for that 20-year
forgiveness or just tearing it down as
quick as possible do you hear what you
just just the idea of like well one
option is waiting 20 years
not my favorite no terrible option uh
the better option is for you to take
control of this and get rid of this in
way under 20 years and you can do it
so the 235 000 I'm assuming it's made up
of a bunch of smaller loans
I have about 30 000 in private and the
rest is all federal okay but they're
made up of a ton of loans there's other
like a dozen or more loans involved here
or is it a few big ones
it's a bunch of small ones yes okay so
here's what to do to help you have some
peace about this instead of staring at
the mountain let's break this up into
little chunks so lay them all out from
smallest to largest and we're going to
start attacking the small one first
that's baby step two baby step one
thousand bucks in the bank I assume you
have that already
I do how much other money do you have
sitting around that's liquid
uh that's liquid
maybe Seven Grand great that's gonna
knock out the credit card and probably
one of the smallest student loans the
next smallest one
yeah yeah I could see that boom we
already have some progress don't we
Mackenzie we didn't need Biden yeah
uh listen Mackenzie
um here's the uncomfortable truth about
the situation you're in is a big old
hole
and there is not going to be some night
on a white horse coming to save you on
this one
there's just not and so all George and I
were talking about this earlier off air
I
there is this moment when I want
something else to be true so bad and
this can be any number of things this
could be like I wanted my dad to live
forever and he passed away I wanted this
relationship with my romantic partner to
go forever and they stepped out on me
like these things this happens all
throughout our life
and the we gotta grieve this thing that
we hoped for that we wanted to happen
that didn't happen and then we have to
ask ourselves okay what are we gonna do
next because most of the time nobody's
coming to rescue us
and so you saying I am an electrical
engineer I'm a first gen student what
that means to me is that I've worked
with first-gen students my entire career
here's what I know about you you are
really really smart
right
thank you no no I'm not just blowing
smoke at you you're a first-gen
electrical engineering student you are
very smart correct
sometimes
except when it comes to the loans you
took out you looked around your classes
and your classmates were mostly dumber
than you correct I know this is a fact
right
I don't know yes you do she's so humble
exactly you are correct and I think that
you're being underpaid
I think you can make more money than
seventy thousand dollars you might not
be at the most comfortable firm right
now or you might like I really want to
be doing these kind of buildings instead
of these kind of buildings right now
we're gonna take a few years and we're
gonna go for money we're gonna work
really hard to make a great salary and
we're going to get this thing paid off
and I'm telling you from a guy that has
six figures of student loan debt myself
on the other side of this you will be an
Unstoppable force in anything you do
you get what I'm saying because here's
what I think I think there's some shame
wrapped up in this like how can I be so
smart and so dumb at the same time and I
want you to put that down the whole
system preys on first gen students
the good news is you are among 43
million other people who feel the same
way so you're not even special
not even a snowflake like we all call it
right so there's a lot of people in this
together the difference is you're gonna
be the one who gets out and doesn't wait
on someone else to save the day and make
no mistake this will be awful
your friends are gonna be buying fancy
cars and you're gonna be in the same
stupid car and you're still not gonna
have a home two or three years from now
because you're still gonna be paying
this off in all of your family who
didn't go to college it's gonna be like
MacKenzie you did all this work why
aren't you buying this and why aren't
you dressed like this because they have
a picture of success that is not based
in reality and if they're not the ones
paying your student loan bills that's
right
so they don't get a say so you commit to
this in front of a couple I don't know
10 15 million people will you commit I'm
I'm done with this I'm gonna I'm gonna
knock it out
absolutely yes dude we'll we will walk
with you every step of the way I want
you to hang on the line I'm going to
send you a copy of here we're gonna see
a bunch of stuff I'm gonna send you a
copy of Total Money make over the book
and we're gonna put you in Financial
Peace University and give you a year
subscription to every dollar and it's
the it's the premium budgeting app that
we all use it's just it's first class
it's the best there is and it's going to
teach you the the step by step by step
process on how to get out of this thing
forever and as a first gen student who's
just now making big money who's I mean
you're you're going to be first gen in a
lot of different stages here and so this
program is going to help you not only
get out of debt but build wealth on the
back end too and we're going to walk
with you every step of the way in about
six months you're gonna get really
frustrated because you're going to be
working really hard and this number's
still going to be big I want you to call
us back and we will give you another pep
talk or wherever you get stuck we'll be
here to help you along the way but this
is going to be getting roommates getting
a side job getting a different job that
pays more for your full-time gig cutting
your expenses down to nothing but then
you're gonna be able to throw 30 40
Grand at this debt and all of a sudden
you see the light if you're near this
tunnel you go three years from now four
years from now five years from now I'm
completely debt free and then we can
look at home ownership down the road and
in four years of McKenzie who has worked
her way through electrical engineering
school and paid off all their debt
there's literally no stopping her no and
go watch borrowed future if you want to
know why John and I are so riled up
about this delay dreams are on the other
side of student loans and that is why
we're angry at them you can rise above
it this is the Ramsey Show we'll be
right back
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show triple eight
eight two five five two two five the
Ramsey Show question of the day is
sponsored by neighborly your hub for
home services from repairs and
maintenance to Remodeling and upgrades
neighborly's trusted Home Service
provides you providers have trained
local experts who can handle just about
any job so go to neighborly.com to find
and schedule service today dude I just
wear out our maintenance guys here at
the building Winston and those
guidelines oh yeah I need a contractor I
need a deck person you got a roofer
person neighborly Saves the Day they've
got it all man DIY more like DIY just
hire a guy yeah right yeah I'm just
pitching tag lines for them I don't
think they want that one I don't think
that one's free no hey here's here's the
question of the day comes from Chris in
the Ramsay baby steps Community we are
on baby step two and I'm having a hard
time emptying our savings aside from the
thousand bucks to pay down debt as our
emergencies are never less than a
thousand bucks
just trying to get over this mental hump
I feel like I will be forced to charge
something like a car repair or furnace
which just happened then we will he will
be thrown back so far I'm just really
scared I think this is the place to
focus this is more mental and emotional
that is financial correct it's almost
entirely
um and as my friend Dr Lane Norton says
data is more important than feelings a
lot of the times right so
ah it's easy to look back and go all
these repairs cost this much money be
honest with yourself and they they
usually don't a couple a couple times
they do I've had to replace a roof I had
to replace you know part of a car like
they can be expensive most of the time
they're not and George you can tell me
if I'm wrong but they're not designed
for that this is designed to light a
fire under you to get you running and
gunning absolutely it's not meant to
cover the big emergencies that's why we
call it a starter emergency fund and
baby step one and here's the truth if an
emergency happened what would you do if
you had a thousand bucks and it was a
fifteen hundred dollar emergency well
you'd pause the baby steps you'd pause
it and you'd stack up cash as fast as
you could in order to cover it and then
you're back on the wagon the problem is
right now you feel like you're safe even
though you owe lenders a whole bunch of
money that's the confusing part to me is
like if you wanted safety so badly why
are you sitting there with money in the
bank while owing people money
to me true safety true Freedom comes on
the other side of being completely debt
free and not owing anyone anything to
where if everything went down and I know
John you like to think about this
scenario I gotta play it man a wing
don't want anything is the best way to
go it's it's just total freedom that's
right it's total freedom I don't want it
the government telling me what's it to
stop owing people money I don't want my
boss to stop owing people money right
it's super simple you have more options
and so on Saturday you're coming in at
eight o'clock actually no I'm not I'm
actually not coming at eight o'clock
I've got other stuff with my family and
you can make that choice you don't owe
anybody any money right so it's just
total freedom
so you can do this again it's I like
being a little bit scared because it
fuels me to get rid of this debt once
and for all and stop playing the game
and it takes something that drastic yeah
in order to get there and let Chris let
me affirm you
um I work here and a thousand dollars in
one in us in a savings account would
would I would not be able to sleep I
would be so terrified I got two little
kids I got a like wife I wouldn't be
able to breathe and that's kind of the
point
I would be so paranoid that I would be
delivering pizzas at night and driving
people to uh ubering before work in the
morning I would be so maniacal about
getting this thing knocked out so that I
could get this this savings account up
and that is the point most people don't
take us seriously when we say gazelle
intense that's an animal running for its
life because it's about to be ripped
apart and torn apart and eaten and
killed and that's the level of
intentional we want people to have and
so I'm With You Chris if I had a
thousand bucks in a savings account that
was it I would not be able to breathe
and that's the point that's the point so
let this fear drive you to none of us
are eating out nobody's getting new
shoes none of us are going to the movies
we're cutting all the subscriptions
we're getting rid of everything so we
can get this crap done so that Mama and
Dad can sleep again that's right all
right let's go out to Marissa in
Richmond what's up Marissa how we doing
Hi how are y'all all right how are you
what's up
I had a question about
um 53 and my husband's 54 and we did
Financial Peace University about 15
years ago but now our kids have both
finished college and we're just trying
to figure out what to do so we don't
have very much money in retirement we
only have about ninety thousand dollars
each
and we do have five houses two of which
are paid off and three we have mortgages
on we rent them all out
so we're just trying to decide should we
try to pay off the mortgages or should
we throw money into our IRAs and do that
makeup and you know put as much away as
we can for that
okay so you're essentially using these
rental homes as a replacement for your
401k
currently yeah that that was right the
intent yes and that can work what's the
net profit of these properties currently
per year
um well
well they
on my list she's like any money do that
tonight that's some good homework for
you but here's why I asked you my hunch
my hunch is that you should sell one of
these your least favorite rental
property and use it to pay off the
others or sell two of them and pay off
the others to where you have you have a
fully paid for Real Estate portfolio to
where you get to keep 100 of that profit
and it'll lower your expenses
and once you do that then I would start
shoveling money into retirement accounts
which you have some great catch-up
contributions you can make after 50.
right yeah but you don't think my only
hesitation about that is then is it bad
if we don't have the deductions for the
rental properties because you know the
deductions are not what's going to save
your butts in retirement
you're you're stepping over a dollar to
pick up a quarter
and so that's that's not a like a wealth
hack just to use the deductions that you
can't live off of that in retirement
well you can live off of is having very
little expenses and so you can make six
grand a month and be okay because you
don't need to cover 10.
so that's that's where I would want to
be in retirement is have as few expenses
as possible paid for home paid for
rental property and a pile of money in
Investments I think that's a
well-rounded portfolio
okay so however you guys want to go
about paying off the debt is great but
it sounds like right now you're feeling
the pinch with retirement I would want
more cash flow to funnel into retirement
which means getting some of these rental
properties uh to getting rid of the
mortgages on them and George in some
ways Marissa and her husband just just
went about this backwards right most
people will fund their Roth IRAs they'll
fund another IRA and then if they've got
money left over they'll start thinking
about buying rental properties they just
went ahead and bought rental properties
and so we're going to sell a couple of
them get clear the debt and so they're
gonna have their primary house maybe two
maybe three other houses that are
completely free and clear theirs and
then they're going to start backfilling
that yeah and some people I mean they're
clearly very comfortable with real
estate which is awesome yeah we love
real estate yeah pretty much Dave's
entire portfolio and he's worth hundreds
of millions of dollars is just real
estate and mutual funds right it's that
boring and it's and he's that wealthy so
you tell me he's not at work on Friday
that's all I'm saying we're here that's
right what are we doing wrong John but
it's a great question I don't lot of
people are wondering well I should get
into the real estate investment game
here's when we tell you too that that's
a good move you have a paid for personal
residence and you pay cash for
investment property that is an insane
thing to say in today's world I
understand how controversial that is but
it's also the right way to do it to
reduce risk and maximize your wealth and
the question is always would you take a
loan against your personal house to buy
a rental property don't tempt America
with a good time they might do that
that's a great idea I'll take out the
HELOC use that as the down payment these
are the wealth strategies that you find
on social media these days and it's all
from Real Estate Bros and permanent life
insurance Bros who all have a vested
interest to get you to do that thing we
don't we want you to build wealth
independently not dependent on if this
thing goes right it's all it's like
putting in a parlay bet man like you got
to make every shot what a crazy way to
live just enjoy the game yeah so that's
the way to do it and obviously I'm a big
fan of using your retirement accounts
tax advantage accounts are awesome your
401k your IRA you can become a
millionaire you invest 100 bucks a month
from 25 to 65 you're going to be a
millionaire a boring one a hundred
dollars a month boring one so don't feel
like you have to do something fancy or
like doing nothing down on real estate
prob you don't have to own real estate
Investments your whole life you can have
a paid for house and millions of dollars
in the bank it's a Choose Your Own
Adventure just don't do something stupid
and don't do debt stay away from drugs
and debt there you go don't do drugs and
don't do debt that is the new George
camel t-shirt hey it's another hour in
the books here on the Ramsey Show and I
think the guys in the booth I want to
thank you America for listening to us we
will be right back right here on the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
hey George Campbell here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramsaysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter foreign
[Music]
ERS of rangi solutions broadcasting from
the PODS moving and storage Studio it's
the Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth do work they love and have
incredible relationships I'm John
deloney joined here by my good friend
George Campbell basically half the
Beatles John and George and we are
taking your calls on money life whatever
you got going on work relationships
marriage mental health whatever you got
going on we got an opinion triple eight
eight two five five two two five and
George before we go to the calls I want
to talk about this article that's out
how much money does it take to be happy
oh that's a Hot Topic so is this a hot
take on a Hot Topic it is well we we
covered something similar on Smart money
happy hour saying is there a magic
salary for happiness and great pitch to
your own show well thank you you should
go check it out but this is a this is
actually Based on data instead of
opinions
so one study said happiness Peaks at 75
000 in income now economists say it's
higher by a lot by a lot yeah so that I
remember the data that data's been
around forever and it's kind of become
like a like a folk tale right now
inflation John like 70 grand you're poor
yeah yeah that's the that's the vibe
um all right so let's go through this
um
the question uh so it's it's hired by a
lot tell me how much more
new research from a Nobel prize-winning
Economist and fellow researchers provide
a fresh answer money does appear to
boost happiness at least for some people
up to earnings of five hundred thousand
dollars
wow okay I'm gonna go with a yes on that
one so if you make 501 000 you might be
miserable you make 4.99 you're crushing
the game so this feels almost silly John
because we went from 75 grand to half a
million dollars right
because the idea was after 75 grand you
kind of plateau happiness wise right
this is saying you plateau at 500 Grand
right it's not really accurate um and
there is I think this is important to
note there is a smaller group of people
for whom higher incomes don't make much
diff much difference for this unhappy
Group which I think George is probably
in this group it's comprised of about 15
of people the relationship between
happiness and income is different with
additional money failing to improve
their sense of well-being once they hit
about a hundred grand and so there is
just yours right people who choose
um and I use that word intentionally who
choose I'm just gonna be kind of a grump
right they're just not it's not going to
help anything but uh just get the way it
is and we all know those people in our
lives well I see there's two groups of
people there's one group that
legitimately doesn't make enough money
to cover their bills and survive right
so if you're in survival mode you do
need more money I'm not gonna act like
well you can make any amount of money
and be happy sure that's true we can go
to villages in Africa and find joy that
we could not find on any Street Corner
in America right that is true there's
another group of people who actually
make good money but they have piles of
debt and they're overspending and
they're keeping up with the joint Jones
is they're not content with who they are
and no amount of money can fix that on
one hand or that dollar amount has
become their scorecard for their for
their self-worth and it keeps moving I
have to make this 200 000 or I'm a loser
and my dad's never gonna tell me he's
proud of me and my wife's Gonna Leave me
and then you get 200 000 you realize oh
my life is exactly the same way it was
before I could just I have a nicer
toaster and a cooler blender and then it
moves on you well I need like 300 and it
just keeps moving and moving and moving
and moving well and there's there's also
a piece of this where you go if you make
three four hundred thousand dollars you
might have a very stressful job that
might kill you early yeah I'll never
forget that was one of the most
important lessons I learned young um I
had a mentor who
allowed me to follow it to Shadow him
and some some pretty important meetings
and I remember leaving going oh he makes
way more than me and he earns that money
like his life is hard man because just
all the stuff he's responsible for and
so yeah there's they don't hand out two
or three or four hundred thousand
dollars you got to work for that money
and it's a hard life but even then I
like working really hard I like working
really hard I like working long hours
and I like making great money but I have
to know that that is not going to
when I look in the mirror I'm not it's
not going to give me peace right what's
going to give me peace is really
extraordinary relationships a great
marriage good relationships with
relationships with my kids right healthy
balance with the seasons of work
sometimes they're wild but sometimes I
get some more family time that's going
to give me a peaceful life and
the more money you make the more money
you can give away and we don't talk
about that enough there are some
extraordinary
um generosity that happens with people
who make great money well and science
shows that people who give are more
joyful that's right they have lower
blood pressure that's right they have
less stress in their lives they're more
fulfilled and so there's a lot of
components to this but I think the main
teaching that I Come Away with is saying
if you're in debt get out of debt and
see if that increases your happiness
regardless of your income number two
find a career that you actually enjoy
versus trying to aim at a certain number
and going I'm willing to do whatever job
it takes to make 200 Grand a year you
might be miserable right and some people
might be better off working for 50 Grand
a year doing something they love with no
debt hanging around them that's right
that person can be way happier than
someone making five except and if you
are miserable at 75 grand chances are
you're going to be miserable at 250
Grand you go with you that's right and
so if you don't actually dig into the
roots of that and you know like your
book own your past change your future
and dig into the trauma and the shame
and the baggage and the reasons you're
trying to do all this then no money will
be enough and we see this data on this
people who make 250 Grand are living
paycheck to paycheck so don't ever say
to yourself well if I just made 250
Grand my life would be better you might
have lifestyle creep and you might think
you could go with your car in a nicer
house because now you have to keep up
that's right and so there's a lot of
lessons to be learned here but what I
always go back to is the baby steps work
regardless of if you make 50 Grand or
300 Grand living debt free and having an
emergency fund of the bank will give you
a happier life and that's one component
you still have to have good
relationships good Community have a job
that you enjoy that doesn't add stress
to your life so we don't want you to
have a flat tire in any specific area of
life you got to be well-rounded yeah
well I I I I love that this um folklore
this this myth has been busted right and
I also love that we can have a
conversation
man getting to a number and thinking
that's a Finish Line is just not how
life works it can help it can help and I
think it's good that we can now be a
little less
um dishonest if you will 200 000 bucks
can solve a lot of problems it can make
your life easier but it won't your dad's
not going to call you if you hadn't
called you yet he's not going to call
you and say you know what now I'm proud
right yeah um you're not going to have a
dysfunctional marriage and suddenly your
wife's gonna go ah there we go now it's
better it's just not how that works
right
um
hmm so let me ask you this George
instead I was going to take another call
but I'm not gonna do that
um smart man
on on Smart money happy hour
with this particular conversation what
kind of feedback did you get
uh well the comment section was Spirited
as usual John uh one person said
George's comedy is underrated I
appreciate that
um but a lot of people
said you know what that's true because
they've realized that their income is
one factor it's one piece of the
equation we say your income is your
greatest wealth building tool we don't
say it's your joy building tool
yeah exactly and so it's one piece of
the equation when we get our money right
it allows us to look up and focus on
relationships and sleep better at night
which then gives us a better life so get
your money right and that's the
foundation you can use to fix the other
areas thanks hey triple eight eight two
five five two two five this is the
Ramsey Show we'll be right back
[Music]
foreign
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
Shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed Perfect Fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
thank you
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the Ramsey Show let's go
out to Sam I am in Little Rock what's up
Sam
what's up guys how we doing
very well how are y'all outstanding
outstanding what's up
so I'm looking for wisdom on you told
the wrong show my brother wrong show
it's so wrong that I immediately busted
out laughing all right so very sweet uh
yeah you know my wife and I have been
paying off debt for about 14 months and
next week when our paychecks hit we're
done with that and the week after that
uh when my bonus hits we're done with
baby step three yeah so
I I'm just looking for that the mindset
that you know y'all had when
when you got done paying off that right
like what does that look like
well we say you move from intensity to
intentionality once you hit baby step
four and so there's not a lot that
changes as far as your habits of you're
still on a budget
you just let your foot off the gas as
far as you know working three jobs
because you had to to get to safety you
made it to Shore and so now the goal is
how do we start building towards the
future instead of paying for the past
and there's a lot of things you can kind
of put on autopilot like 15 into your
retirement at that point
that that can be an easy thing to do it
can also be really hard because you now
want to use that money but it still has
an allocation it still has to go
somewhere and go to work for you but
now's the time to actually go okay what
are some spending goals we have we
haven't been able to do that for a while
where do we want to go on vacation hey
it's time to upgrade that car let's do
that home renovation and cash flow it
and so that's where you sit down with
your spouse and really start to put
those goals on paper and make that a
part of your daily monthly yearly
routines so one of the things I've seen
people do Sam that helps them be
successful is it's so wise that you're
thinking through this now usually what
happens is people become debt free they
scream and yell and jump up and down in
the living room they wake up the next
morning and their lives are exactly the
same there's not many bills next month
and then they kind of Go Bananas they go
crazy and they don't maybe they'll go
back into debt but they kind of blow the
budget and just go out to eat and go to
bananas and then they start to figure
out like oh crap what do we got to do
you get you guys are a couple months
ahead of that here's where you get to do
and I want you to shift from survival to
fun I would love for you and your wife
to go out and have a long really really
nice dinner like an obnoxious one and
with the intention of what do we want
our lives to look like in the next two
to three years and what do we want our
lives to look like in fifth let's just
dream and be silly about it
um we want a house here and we want the
East Wing to look like this like let's
start dreaming together not just
surviving together and then what you do
is you sit down and say okay here's
what's going to take to get there and
some of these things are silly some of
them are real and we're going to begin
to build a path that's going to get us
there but now we're building a path
looking forward we're not just running
through the night to not get eaten by a
lion you see the difference there
yeah but yeah I do here's what's really
important you have to intentionally
change your identity our identity was we
are a couple who will do whatever it
takes to get out of debt and if you
don't go through some sort of ritual if
you will to change your identity one of
you is going to hang on to that identity
and the other one's gonna get really fed
up and frustrated if they can't buy new
shoes and then you're gonna have this
weird angst in the house you're not
gonna know where it's coming from it's
because you got two competing identities
in the same marriage and so let's turn
our identity who do we want to become
now do you want to be wild generous
people do we want to have our kids pay
half of their college or 100 of their
college or want to pay our house off now
we can start dreaming about whatever
comes next and it's incredible if you
guys can make that turn
yeah that makes sense did when you're
looking at like your fund money and all
that are you taking are you making
separate pots of money for that like I
just I just haven't had it so I don't it
just becomes a line item in your budget
so it's Sam's fun money okay there's an
entertainment there's a vacation sinking
fund so we save up five grand for that
trip six months from now and so that's
all it becomes and I have different
areas there you can only do three things
with money give it save it spend it I
like to do it in that order so set
giving goals that's going to come off
the top set some savings goals so we're
gonna invest 15 percent we're gonna save
up for the car we're gonna save up for
the vacation and then have some spending
goals and go all right we're gonna spend
some money this month we're gonna set it
500 bucks to go out to eat because we
just haven't been able to do that we got
to catch up on all the new restaurants
in Little Rock whatever it is for you
guys but doing that helps me feel
grounded and not like I'm leaning one
way too much because some people go I
have to save save save save I can't
spend a dime Dave said no Dave didn't
say that he said live like no one else
so like later you can live and give like
no one else and it's time to start
leaning into the ladder I think um
I would maybe do it for a couple of
months at a time Sam I just said two to
three years maybe say hey we're gonna
spend two months and we're just gonna go
to some restaurants we're gonna eat out
because we haven't done that in so long
and this we're just gonna enjoy some of
these restaurants what you will find is
it will be nice and cool and you're
gonna look forward to going back to
eating at home
and okay you're gonna like somebody else
doing the dishes and it's going to feel
good to have somebody else clean up
after you and then you're gonna get
tired of the 50 and 60 and 70 bills just
at regular old restaurants these days
and you're gonna say ah I'd rather go
back home right so it's just but do it
do it just here's the key just make sure
you budget for it just put it in the
budget
yeah
okay
and thank you this will be wonky okay
just be if y'all have an argument you
get frustrated it's like oh I had my eye
on this guitar and she's like well I had
my eye on you never buying another
guitar like those expect those things to
happen that's just marriage it's just
life that's two people doing life
together
um but you're not broken and you're not
something something's not wrong it's
just about turning the corner and
changing identities together which dude
I just think that's going to be a blast
man it's gonna be a blast all right
let's roll out to Holly in Davenport
what's up Holly how we doing
hey Dr John hey George it's good to talk
to you guys it's great to talk to you
too how we doing
yeah well speaking of changing identity
um I am a new stay-at-home mom and I do
kind of lonely and isolated
um you know I worked I worked for 20
years
um before my husband and I had kids and
I'm about a year into this thing and
it's just like I said kind of lonely
isolated and I just
I want to be here with my kids I think
it's selfish it would be very selfish of
me to send my kids to daycare so I can
you know go work we don't need the money
I need to be here with my kids but I
want to find happiness in it I want to
find joy in it and I I just can't I just
haven't been able to hmm
um man
if you were in front of me I would ask
you if it's okay to give you a hug
because I this this is one of the most
common conversations I have across the
country and it's the opposite I have the
opposite conversation as well
um I can't stay at home and I feel like
I should or or I should be at work I
want to be at work and I feel like I got
to be at home and then I my kids do
something crazy and then I think mean
thoughts like I wish my kids would stop
smearing crap all of it and then I feel
guilty for having these thoughts and so
I want you to understand you've entered
and you've been in it for a long time
um but you are continuing in to the
vortex that is modern Western world
that is built on a guilt Factory for
mothers you can't damned if you do
damned that's right you're gonna get
judgment on either side and opinions
from the other moms yes you're and
you're going to get opinions from
yourself
that's the issue that I'm having you
know I can care less about the outside
world and honestly I think maybe some of
the issue too is that I I don't really
have Community I don't have a lot of
friends I think family doesn't live here
I think that is
um key here's two things I think are key
number one I think you thought it would
feel different
if I make this huge sacrifice the reward
that I'm going to quote unquote feel
inside is going to be worth it and that
feeling's not there but but you did get
a great feeling from being really good
at your professional job and getting a
paycheck deposit in your account and
getting getting out of girls from your
from your co-workers and your
supervisors that felt awesome it was
built-in validation yeah every day it
doesn't feel awesome and when you make
it a great meal and your kids are like I
don't like this it's gross or Timmy
pushed me and you're like how about I
push you off you know so number one you
have to every time you have those
feelings just call them out
I thought this was gonna feel
differently and I feel like I want to
karate chop somebody I'm not going to
but I feel it the second thing is you
nailed it you gotta get a group of women
in your life and that's the hard weird
ugly annoying part it's almost like
dating again except harder you got to
make a choice to get some women in your
life
um Tessa Romero check her out on
Instagram Tessa Romero she's great with
Mom new mom's mindset shift she's
awesome and um make it a point to get
some friends you're worth it this is the
Ramsay show we'll be right back
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's happening this is the Ramsey
Show I'm John deloney joined by my good
friend George Campbell and on the
debt-free stage we have Anna and
Isabella and Nicholas what is happening
hey happy to be here how we doing good
all the way from the great state the
only country that matters Texas that's
right very cool all right so you're here
from Texas and you're doing your debt
free screams how much do we pay off I
paid off 38
473 dollars
38 470.
um making how much so I started with 54
000 and ended at 98 000. is that just
you yeah just me what do you do
so I work for say and I do sales for
power distribution equipment and the
first year of my
debt-free snowball I did Uber and I sold
cookies and I also sold everything
that's a lot you had a third kid and
they're gone too yeah it's gone so how
long did it take to pay this off 21
months amazing oh so you got after it
after it after it yeah especially the
first year so what kind of debt was the
38 000. it was credit cards car
um AC repairs some chairs
and some chairs yeah my dining chairs
Wow Come on was that because of like
it's a zero percent or was that you were
so broker like I gotta get chairs and
put them on the car like how did that
work
it was a really good deal
[Laughter]
so I needed chairs mine were falling
apart and so I got them on like PayPal
for paint on payments wow so it took me
a few months and it took a few months
for the chairs to get here too so all
right 21 months ago
um you're sitting by yourself in
Montgomery Texas and you've got these
two kids and they're sleeping and you've
got your heads head in your hands yeah
and you say it's time what tell us about
what happened so
my that free snowball started in 2021
okay but I heard about the snowball
in 2017 or 2019 was I was still married
and we had we were so normal we had all
the debt all the credit cards and every
time we would get a chunk of money
at bonus uh
taxes whatever we would pay off a credit
card and then we would start paying off
the other and by the time we got paid
paid off the other we
already racked up on that one you
collected some more so it was a vicious
cycle
and then
I remember sitting down that year 2017
2018 and I just Googled how to pay off
credit cards because I was raised to
never use credit and so I was raised to
live and listen I make on saving money
that's insane it's insane and I went to
college that free too like I worked my
foot off but
um somewhere along the way we started
wrecking off that and
I wasn't taught how to like pay it off I
mean I didn't know you know we had so
much that it was it just seemed
impossible so I remember sitting down in
my dining table
on the dining chairs no no there was I
was married I was married yeah good
um and so
because it wasn't me now to figure it
out
and so I just like Googled how to pay
credit cards and it was all this
um you know that consolidation moved
your credit cards to this card and I was
like that makes no sense
and a few pages
you know took that far to get to a
Ramsey pages to get to Ramsay and it
only said is like snowball and I read it
and it makes sense and so I presented it
to my ex-husband now and nothing
happened we just kept living the way we
were living and then 2020 happened and
um
my marriage was falling apart and I lost
my job
oh no
and then um my dad passed away
and
um so in the summer of 2020 I filed for
divorce and I got a job the job that I
have now
annual sales so I just knew that this
guy is the limit and I started with a
base
um
base salary and then
it just went up from there but it took a
while and so I filed for divorce and
three months later it was finalized and
on paper
you know like in my head
I could afford things like I could
afford my house and I could afford I
changed my cars I downsized
um and I was totally okay with that
but in my head it would I could afford
my house payment on groceries and just
the basic things and even the minimum
payments on my credit card and then I
couldn't and so
things in those six months between my
divorce being finalized and
when I started
there were weeks where I had like eight
dollars to my name wow wow terrifying
right it is yeah so you went from an
emotional crawl to a financial Sprint
yeah and how do you even do that I'm
just
that's just the kind of person I am I go
from zero to 100 and like no time
wow so you're a hero okay so what does
it feel like now it's great I love it
like I'm never going back I like
whenever you whenever you go home and
you watch the clip of this yeah I want
you to watch your body language because
when you tell your story about
your body remembers your marriage
falling apart your dad passing away your
whole body shrinks and then just asking
you how does it feel now it's like
somebody turned all the lights on in the
lobby out there yeah I mean everyone
like don't stop living the way that you
are because everyone I know is normal
and you know I did like a no spend
February because I was like I'm tired of
this and I remember I had 300 and I was
like oh my gosh this is so awesome I
have 300 without even having a budget
and then I downloaded every dollar app
in March
and I kind of toyed around with that
going back to my bank statements like
December January and even February and I
said my budget and April it was on and
um how did you get these two little ones
to follow with you
oh I mean if I did ubereats they were in
the car with me oh fantastic so they got
to see Mom hey you have given them a
legacy shifting gift because they're
never gonna forget that and in college
somebody's gonna offer be like hey let's
just go get a credit card and you're
gonna be like no I remember driving
around with my mom and I I wasn't shy
about talking to them about the money
problems I mean I didn't you know I
didn't
um burden them yeah but I did share like
no we're not doing this because you know
we're gonna do this we did go to
birthday parties but instead of bringing
the flashy gift I brought like a token
for frozen yogurt yeah and a handmade
card and a handmade bag or whatever and
so that's how we they contributed and it
was a lot of nails well more is caught
than taught and what they caught from
watching Mom be a hero is gonna sit with
them for the rest of their lives I hope
so with that goon on the college campus
going here okay here's here's a credit
card and a free pizza he's gonna stick
on that game like no absolutely I saw my
mom fight to get over this but I also I
also need you to know this there are
millions of single parents watching this
right now yeah and they can't breathe
and they got two little kids yeah and
their world's falling apart and then mom
calls and says dad's not doing well and
you have single-handedly shined a light
in a really dark moment we can all sit
up here and talk and they're like oh
it's really easy for you guys to
and Anna you've taken away the darkness
in so many lives by just saying no more
no more no more you know I hate the
spotlight but the fact the sharing my
story and I know that there's a single
parent out there Mom or Dad lots of them
that are going through this and they
don't see the light and I didn't see the
light you're an inspiration and all you
need is the process and it works
Isabella and Nicholas your mom's a
gangster you know never to mess with her
correct oh yeah excellent that's awesome
well we've got the living give box for
you uh that includes The Total Money
Makeover of course baby steps
millionaires your next chapter and your
story and a year of Financial Peace
University so that you can kick-start
someone else's Journey thank you and you
can give it away all right so we've got
38 470 bucks paid off in 21 months
making 30 54 to 98 000 dollars
From the Ashes the Phoenix Rose and here
she is standing before us painted us all
off it's time to do your debt free
screen let's Let It Rip
one oh no three two
one wear that
[Applause]
awesome
I wish my mom was that cool back then
you know what a hero
I love my favorite part of the show is
debt free screams especially the
excuse Busters yeah but I have yeah but
I have yeah but I know Anna nothing's
stopping her and I know Hannah not with
her finances not with her career not
with nothing if you are listening to
this no one can stop you either if you
just say today's the day this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
today's scripture of the day is Matthew
5 14-15 you are the light of the world a
town built on a hill cannot be hidden
neither do people light a lamp and put
it under a bowl instead they put it on
its stand and get and it gives light to
everyone in the house
brene Brown says numb the dark and you
numb the light
numb the dark and you numb the light I
love that love that love that all right
let's go out to Richard in Jacksonville
Florida what's up Richard
hey how's it going outstanding how are
you
doing great
um so basically so I've been kind of
following Dave Ramsey since 2013 where I
actually read his book I'm in the Coast
Guard and actually that's when I got
introduced to it very cool my dad got me
the book and um you know I've been
trying to follow those baby steps as
best as possible my question to you all
is we're about to uh PCS over to Puerto
Rico okay and um we live near
Jacksonville Florida and
um we're not sure if we should be
selling our house or renting it uh we do
owe a little bit on it but it is mostly
paid off uh we know that we could sell
it for 300 000 or about 300 000 and uh
or rent it out for about two thousand
dollars a month
so we owe 76 on it at a 2.87 percent uh
conventional loan
and we bought it for 215. so basically
in three years we got it down to 76. way
to go
um so how long are you gonna be in
Puerto Rico
it's gonna be for three years and our
housing and utilities are going to be
included because we're going to be in
government housing so we don't have to
worry about any payments so basically I
can get straight to step six because I
won't have no house if I were to sell
however it could be an income stream
um especially with the low interest rate
and I'm I'm totally against it I don't
have any other debt
um so this is pretty much what I'm
working with so I I'll I'm going to
answer you what I would do if this is
just my family and George can give you a
more numbers driven answer
um I would not want to be a landlord
on the other side of the world
um and I know the other side of the
world is relative here but I would want
to be a landlord one state over when the
dealing with a company that's going to
come in and manage the property or when
the air conditioner goes out or the
dishwasher leaks and causes a the floor
subfloor I just want to deal with that
I'd much rather have cash in a um just a
regular money market account if you will
let it sit there throw it in a Vanguard
account for a few years and just let it
sit so that when we come back to the
States and quite honestly Puerto Rico is
incredible if you come back to the
States
um then you can buy a place when you
come back and would you for sure be
stationed back in Jacksonville when you
came back
uh no so it will actually likely not be
back in Jacksonville all right for sure
I'm actually from Puerto Rico okay
that's home for me but it'll probably be
who knows probably likely probably
Washington DC is my guess okay yeah then
I'm I'm selling and here's another
option for you Richard when you if you
do sell it let's say you net 200 Grand
is that fair to say after fees
sure if you just park that 200 Grand in
a high yield savings account which right
now we're tracking at about four percent
you would make eight grand a year
guaranteed
and so when you look at renting this
place out even for two grand you still
have expenses Property Management you've
got to pay the mortgage you may not even
net the eight grand in a year
and so I'm taking the hassle factor out
of here knowing you're not going to come
back I'm going to sell it and I know
you're worried because the interest rate
is so good but you're going to be in a
different place when you come back
financially emotionally mentally
physically where you're located so I'm
selling this thing if I'm in your shoes
absolutely
okay does this sound good let's see
sounds like a very straightforward
answer there there you go that's all you
get out of it I know I know it sounds so
cool to be like I'm a landowner and I've
got a rental property back it it's free
money but man it feels really good to
have a couple hundred thousand dollars
in a bank account too I mean especially
with the interest rates right now in
savings accounts yeah they're doing
they're doing it you can do better there
than you can dealing with a renter when
you've got a mortgage on the place Hey
when's the last time you were excited
about a Monday can't remember oh that
was rhetorical that was what you're
talking about what if instead of waking
up exhausted you felt exhilarated you
can't wait to get to work because it's
another day to fulfill your passion in a
world where there's bare minimum Monday
and there's quiet quitting it's clear
people are craving meaningful work but
finding the career you were born to do
can be difficult when you don't have the
right tools that's why career expert in
Ramsay personality Ken Coleman created
the get clear career assessment to help
you discover your top talents passions
and a clear mission statement that'll
help you find the work the world needs
you to do after taking the quick
assessment you'll get a custom Report
with everything you need to take that
first step towards a meaningful career
go to
ramseysolutions.com get clear to start
your journey and take the get clear
assessment today that's
ramseysolutions.com slash get clear all
right let's go out to Salt Lake City
Utah and talk to Carlos what's up Carlos
dude
I never thought that would be on the on
on this show so I'm big fans of you guys
um I have a question so me and my
brothers we own a plumbing and HVAC
business
and um we're having a little a little
issue with um with pay so we're able to
to pay ourselves
um and our company like during the our
busiest season is between may all the
way to the probably around November and
we did 1.1 million but these slow
Seasons December January February and
March were like we're barely swinging by
we lost one employee because we couldn't
keep him that busy so my question is is
should we
just take out like a line of credit
to pay ourselves and because we still
got to pay our master plumber and we
have to pay
um
accountants and we still got to pay
truck payments we have I think one one
or two truck payments
so hold on do you have enough work are
y'all making enough money you have
enough business cash flow to pay your
bills
yeah uh
um do you have any debt on the business
currently
the only thing that we have is a is two
trucks on there we have a loan for two
trucks what's that amount to
that amounts to eighteen thousand okay I
don't think the solution here is to go
into debt to keep the business afloat
and that problem is going to continue
compounding the better solution is to
figure out either how do we have enough
Revenue to cover those months that were
down or even better how do we find even
a different line of work where we can
make this sustainable December through
March to bring in some Revenue
but I would not take a line of credit to
pay yourselves
you're if you do that brother you are
digging a hole that one slow month will
bear you man
you end up having to sell a truck to
make uh the line of credit payment and
you're gonna find yourself in a mess it
will eventually tank your business to go
this route
so I actually go to the root of the
problem and fix that which is we got to
figure out how do other businesses
create Revenue December through March
are those the months that you're
struggling
yeah so December through March April the
end of April is when we kind of start
getting a little bit busy it starts
getting a little warmer okay people so
yeah that's usually our our busiest
season so here's what I would recommend
you do Carlos I would recommend you
take two or three guys in in Salt Lake
City who are plumbers that you trust
that have been doing this for a while
take them out for coffee
just business owner business owner and
say hey what do you guys do between
December and April just asking you
straight like we are we're running slow
and the the the annoying word here is
vulnerability it's getting a couple
people you trust and just saying hey
times are rough these four months and
we're starting to think about other
ideas for revenue streams during these
months what does that look like for
y'all and some of them will laugh at you
at some moment so you just take out a
line of credit all right cool great
those are off the table for me what's
another idea and then you're going to
get to some really
um ingenious ideas small business owners
are some of the most creative people in
the world because they have to be right
I know landscaping companies that hang
up Christmas lights during the winter
time because they can't mow Lawns and
they rake leaves and they pick up sticks
and they'll make great money doing that
exactly but but it's a way to just keep
the thing going over time so Carlos the
bottom line here is don't put your small
business in further Jeopardy by tying
its its success to a bank you don't need
any more voices in there man sit down
with some folks get some ideas sit down
with your team and get some ideas and
let's roll forward hey that's it for the
Ramsay show today I want to thank James
and Ben and Ebu and the crew out in the
booth and I want to thank you America
for listening to the show George great
show Good Times man you're getting
better at this appreciate it appreciate
you and everybody listen and take care
of each other be kind and let that
person on the highway next to you let
him over the whole world will be better
for it we'll see you soon
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsesolutions.com and click get started
[Music]